iwu is a town of trinkets billions of
cheap consumer goods can be found here
all year round
Huang yuntra's family has sold
decorations at this market for more than
20 years he's relieved the logistical
problems of running a business during
the coronavirus pandemic have ended
but still the mood here is less than
festive
when the government totally canceled the
pandemic restrictions I became very
confident but recovery is slow which I
didn't predict
economists say China's economic rebound
has peaked after an initial burst of
business activity following the end of
covid-19 restrictions economists say
recent data indicates a possible slowing
of momentum with Imports Contracting
industrial output falling short of
expectations and youth unemployment
hitting a record high
Factory gate prices the price
Distributors paid to producers fell
faster than expected in May as reduced
demand dampens the recovery of the
manufacturing sector that early burst of
optimism that we would see uh you know a
12-month expansion in Chinese economic
activity when the economy reopened I
think that has faulted domestic spending
is also down as people are more careful
with their money choosing to save rather
than Splurge
yes I think there's some hurt from the
pandemic now many shops sell
pre-packaged meals to lower the prices
because consumption is low recovery will
take time
and although travel restrictions have
been lifted data shows more people may
be taking holidays but they're spending
less
economists say there are several reasons
for this one concern is that people are
worrying about their job prospect and we
can see a lot of backpack companies are
laying off people and also private
economies slowing down in some areas and
then deter people from spending more
Huang says he's just happy his business
endured the challenges of the pandemic
these past three years were difficult
but we survived things will become
better and better welcome everybody come
to China for business
despite the lackluster economic Outlook
he says he has to believe in brighter
days ahead
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera iwu China